saul goodman
yeah it's like it's all good man
that guy has a lot of energy
yeah
it's just a name
there's something strange about seeing
someone's personal space opened up to
the world imagine if you disappeared
right now what would the people who came
looking for you find that happened to
saul goodman thanks to ed to disappear
he vanished without a trace and we got a
glimpse of what he left behind most
people craft the appearance they present
to the world saul certainly knew a thing
or two about that and had a real sense
of showmanship but behind closed doors
is there a reason to keep the show going
hey guys pete here today i'm going to
talk about the better call saul season 6
opening teaser one thing that always
came up when discussing the character
saul goodman and just how different he
was from the jimmy mcgill we met back in
the first season of the prequel was that
we never saw anything about his personal
life in breaking bad where did saul go
when he wasn't at his office what did he
do when he went home after a long day of
being walter white's lawyer that curtain
has been pulled back and well it's
something to behold i've already
mentioned most of the easter eggs in my
recap for the episode so i won't linger
that long on those here there were some
interesting facts that came out in
interviews and on the insider podcast
which i do want to get into in this
video and then i just want to discuss
some of the questions that this leaves
me with there were some big ones that
had been out there sort of hanging over
the entire series that it makes you
reconsider personally i was never a fan
of the kim is just at home during the
breaking bad timeline like she was right
there by saul's side and we just never
saw her essentially she was the
mastermind running ice station zebra
with saul being the front man for me it
just felt too cute to try to pull that
and in my mind this over ripe abode
shuts the door on that idea to be fair
kim is turned on by jimmy's scammy side
and is even playing an active role in
creating saul's public persona but i
won't be able to accept that she was
recently living in this place until i
see it the seemingly unnecessary
opulence is what stands out the most no
one jimmy's trying to impress or attract
as potential clients should ever see
this place at the strip mall at the
courthouse i get the idea for the flare
but why would anyone need to have a
golden toilet which leads to the next
question i've always wondered if part of
the soul that we watch is him playing up
the persona being the guy he thought
would attract the type of business he
was after but then there was still a lot
more of jimmy mcgill happening behind
the scenes this teaser seems to show the
opposite that he was way more soul than
we could have imagined and it almost
makes me suspicious when asked about
what we're seeing here showrunner peter
gould said that they were playing with
the idea of whether he took the salt
goodman mask off at the end of the day
or did he leave it on that we see that
the mask has become the man he's
pretending to be salt goodman and now
he's living that life 24 7 or so it
seems so it's interesting because on the
one hand you have that and on the other
you have jimmy holding on to this symbol
of their time together the safiro
stopper and gould went on to say that
this is a citizen kane tribute he
mentioned the scene in that movie where
they go through his mansion this
enormous house and world that he's built
for himself and at the end you find out
there's just one object that has
significance and that the stopper is
sort of their little citizen kane sled
it's something that tells you no matter
what kind of jerk this guy has become
what kind of heartless [ __ ] he's made
himself into he's still holding on to
some of what he had with kim or what he
has with kim now this doesn't change my
mind about kim living there but it does
make me think about that phone call that
he asked francesca to take for him right
before he was disappeared someone was
going to call a pre-determined pay phone
at a pre-arranged time and jimmy wasn't
going to be able to be there to take it
it was also going to happen on his
birthday and there's never been any
other great guesses on who would make it
other than kim so it all makes for a
pretty good setup because it's really
hard to see how this is all going to
play out
as far as how they put it all together
there were a few things that jumped out
in the insider podcast the teaser opens
in black and white with a shot of ties
falling onto a surface it appears to
change color to give us our first sign
that we aren't heading to omaha to see
gene director michael morris revealed
that they achieved this effect by using
black and white ties to start and then
changing to the more colorful one saul
was known for so they used a practical
effect there but when they did the
stopper that was actually all done in
visual effects you see it come out of
the back of the truck and end up in the
gutter and there was no real stopper
involved in filming that shot they also
wanted to choreograph things very
deliberately so they hired a group of
dancers to play the movers peter gold
also brought up all the easter eggs and
of course we noticed all these little
objects and callbacks to previous
seasons but he said that there's also
things they're not quite easter eggs
they're more like pre-easter eggs
they're little things that will only
make sense to you later in the season or
when you've seen it all we saw one
example of that with the hg wells time
machine book that was something that the
camera lingered on that wasn't
immediately recognizable and then it
showed up later in their bedroom on
their nightstand this adds a whole other
dimension because now you have to think
about the significance of everything in
that sequence rather than just the stuff
you recognize as far as the stuff we see
one of those items that might turn out
to be important is this notebook that we
see them put in with some of the other
items a similar looking black book
showed up in one of the promo photos
from a scene that hasn't appeared yet
and when he was asked about this
directly peter gould said that it could
turn out to have a significance you
can't really make anything out looking
at a screenshot but it really stands out
how she opens it and puts it in the box
so it seems likely that there's records
of something that they were doing there
maybe it's in code or something along
those lines and i'll be on the lookout
for it for sure there was one easter egg
i would have never seen on my own this
painting that they're carrying down the
steps is the same one we saw in kim's
apartment there were a couple other ones
i didn't mention in my previous video
the track suits you'll remember jimmy
wearing those in his time when he wasn't
a lawyer there and he was selling the
drop phones and there were stress balls
from cc mobile i think i mentioned the
rest of them and i'll put a link to my
other video if you haven't seen that yet
but i think what came to mind after this
set in was that this is all stuff from
the transition as he was giving up on
the idea of being a lawyer being
accepted in that world doing the right
thing so he could impress chuck and
they're all sort of tied to the slippery
slope that he's been on it'll be
interesting to see the role that kim
plays in accelerating that what her
journey to going after howard will turn
into being and how jimmy becomes the
kind of person that goes out and buys a
golden toilet obviously everything's in
place for him to become saul but he's
gonna have to lose more and he might
even have to give up this idea of kim
being the most important thing in his
life we'll have to wait and see and i
think i'll leave it there let me know in
the comments what you think what you
like the best about this teaser and what
you think about it now that you've had
some time to reflect on it please like
this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon